we are fighting for life
we are
fighting against uh
tanks uh planes uh mortars that the
russian troops are using against us to
destroy us
and but uh russia is also destroying
itself because every shot against
ukraine every shot against ukraine this
is a step
that russia takes to
destroy itself to self-isolate to
poverty to degradation russia everybody
turns
everybody leaves
russia now all who can
think programmers businessmen artists uh
the russian state has never experienced
for decades such a blow to the human
capital
which
the blow that it has inflicted on itself
but it doesn't worry us it's not our
problem our problem our issue is to
preserve ourselves our people our
sciences our community
our businessmen and
artists our people our powerful nation
all our ukrainians
who are defending the country and
bringing peace closer
which is necessary for all the people
last night
there were air raids
all over the country an airport in nipah
was destroyed russian aviation bombs
fell on harkev plus artillery plus
motors there are
fights uh battles in the uh region too
in even they are clearing rubble after a
missile strike there now we know about
nineteen uh deaths there the
ancient chicknighev city is under such a
powerful attack that it has
removed
any claims to the
cultural size to uh to the
ancient ruse they have no soul no memory
russian troops are attacking kiev
the key of by cavans they destroyed four
residential buildings high rises and now
we're talking about five
deaths in kiev
i will say this in russians to you
this is in our capital
in the city
which you refer to always as the mother
of russian cities
which has
made our
peoples
historical and you bombed it today just
people just residential areas you bombed
and then bombed more
we don't need children like that thank
you
the
occupiers
continue to believe the capture of our
capital as their main political aim they
believe that control over kiev will give
them control over ukraine this is absurd
total absurd
from every point of view
to reinforce the defense of kiev and
kiev oblast i appointed alexander pavluk
as the head of the uh key of the
regional uh
uh
administration he used to be the head of
the joint forces operation and alexis
coleba will
uh
assist the military administration so
the key of area and the situation in the
region will be the focus of our
attention and the new commander of the
joint forces operation uh
will be commanded by uh general moscali
of every morning every evening i thank
our military all our heroes who are
courageously defending our country all
those who are stopping
the enemy the enemy which is superior
numerically superior one to ten and i
want to say now to about all the
civilians who died in this war eternal
memory to all those who died for ukraine
an eternal curse on the enemy who took
thousands of lives
today humanitarian corridor has uh
corridors open
partially uh in in several places and in
paltava and
konatop the occupiers uh
undermined the work of humanitarian
corridors in kiev oblast and they are
blocking uh
humanitarian convoy for mariupol for
several days now but slowly step by step
people are leaving the
besieged town on their private vehicles
i want to thank the police the doctors
and all those
uh people who are saving people
i also think our military men and women
i spoke to a summit it's a samuel today
organized by the
britain ukraine's friend boris johnson i
spoke to the united expedition force of
the united kingdom i spoke to the
leaders of the
northern european countries and baltic
states i said what i wanted to say
that all our citizens wanted to say
about nato their help and their
generosity and that not all
of them took
a
moral really collect position on
russia's
uh attack all those 800
800
missiles that struck our country is the
answer to to nato if the doors to the
alliance had been open we wouldn't have
to try to convince the alliance for 20
days to close our skies
to close it to the death brought to the
russian air force however
they don't hear us or don't want to hear
us
some countries in the alliance
have scared themselves
by telling themselves that they cannot
respond they cannot
face
russian
planes and missiles in ukrainian skies
otherwise it would
leave to
lead to escalation or the third world
war but what would they do if russia
goes to europe or other country
they
keep saying the fifth article it's it's
never been as weak as it is now
this is just our opinion
when some members of the alliance was
too scared to be an alliance
capable of defending all that it was
created for for freedom and democracy
humanity and justice we need to
find
currencies
guarantees for our
skies
we need
planes i don't
i still we still want them we will
continue
trying to procure them we need
additional security guarantees for the
country for all the ukrainians but
specific things specific guarantees
legally
bound guarantees so there would never be
any doubts about them and so that there
wouldn't be any excuses that we hear now
when we turn to those who signed the
budapest agreement and and who had the
possibilities to stop the russian
invasion before it started they could
have done it preventively to help
ukraine preventively but the ukraine
will
the sanctions that don't allow to fight
ukrainian men and women there are more
than four million of us in our country
and also millions all over the world
this is a huge power plus our friends
and many countries and our partners we
all have a joint task a national mission
we have to
put such a pressure on russia so that
the price for this ukraine this war
against ukraine will be as painful as
possible that everybody in the world uh
take a moral position and not just
governments but also companies business
large corporations